[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
i
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
no
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well thank you very much thank you
thank you very much so many doctors so
many
fantastic doctors nurses that's great
please sit down
i'm thrilled to be here in north
carolina with so many of these
unbelievable professionals doctors
nurses
and amazing healthcare workers really in
honor of mine
as the world witness during our battle
against the china virus america has the
greatest medical professionals
anywhere on earth
today i will lay out my vision for a
health care system
that puts patients first families first
and
perhaps most importantly for all of us
america first
thank you thank you
under the america first healthcare plan
we will ensure the highest standard of
care anywhere in the world
cutting edge treatment state-of-the-art
medicine groundbreaking cures and true
health security for you and your loved
ones
and we will do it rapidly and it's in
very good order
and some of it has already been
implemented
in short we're delivering better care
with more choice
and a much lower cost and working to
ensure americans have
access to the care they need my plan
expands affordable insurance options
reduces the cost of prescription drugs
will end
surprise medical billing increases
fairness through
price transparency streamlines
bureaucracy accelerates innovation
strongly protects medicare and always
protects patients with pre-existing
conditions
by contrast the democrat party is
pushing a socialist nightmare
their plans will result in rationing
care
denying choice putting americans on wait
lists
driving the best doctors out of medicine
permanently
and delaying life-saving cures
over 130 democrats in congress including
senator harris
have endorsed legislation to outlaw the
private health plans of 180 million
americans on top of it all former vice
president joe biden promised to give
free federal
health care to anyone in the world who
illegally crosses our border
his plan to provide government health
care to illegal immigrants would
bankrupt our health care system
collapse our hospitals and destroy
medicare
while bringing millions and millions of
people
lured into our country
as long as i am president we will
safeguard our borders
and our seniors we are pleased to be
joined today by secretary
of health and human services done a
great job alex azar
alex thank you
and very importantly cms administrator
sima
verma thank you seymour
[Laughter]
a great friend of mine and a great
friend of healthcare frankly
senator bill cassidy phil
representatives michael burgess and greg
murphy
so instrumental thank you thank you
thanks
and many many state and local officials
are here with us thank you very much
since the plague arrived from china we
have seen our doctors nurses first
responders scientists and researchers at
their very best
we slashed red tape to accelerate the
development of life-saving treatments
reducing the fatality rate by 85
since april incredible overall europe
has seen
an almost 50 percent greater excess
mortality rate
than that of the united states and
despite europe's punishing lockdowns
they are now seeing a huge surge very
sadly
in cases under operation warp speed my
administration is developing a vaccine
in record time
it will be distributed before the end of
the year and maybe quite a bit sooner
than that
four vaccines are now in the final stage
of clinical trials
it's just about at the end a lot of
things are looking very good
it is the most ambitious vaccine program
in u.s history probably in any history
the vaccines are being mass produced in
advance
so they can be delivered within 24 hours
of approval
the vaccine will be safe and it will be
effective
it will defeat the virus and it will end
the pandemic
the economy will surge to record highs
you see what's happening with the
numbers that are coming out
records all normal life will
fully resume that will be great and next
year will be one of the greatest years
in the history of our country
from an economic and hopefully in many
other ways
when i was elected i inherited a thing
called
obamacare has anybody heard of obamacare
it was terrible that's the way i feel
too
it was terrible and very very expensive
hurt a lot of people
premiums were too high deductibles were
a disaster
patience had no choice you couldn't keep
your doctor
but by far the worst part of obamacare
was
this thing called the individual mandate
as part of our largest ever tax cut in
the history of the united states
we put in a provision to kill this worst
provision of obamacare the individual
mandate
it was a disaster and it was really the
essence
of obamacare it made you pay a
tremendous amount of money in order to
not have to pay
for health insurance think that you had
to pay a fortune
in order not to have health insurance
it was really terrible and so unfair to
so many destroyed families
we were able to terminate the individual
mandate but kept the provision
protecting patients with
pre-existing conditions it would not
have been
that particular law would never have
been signed if it were otherwise
obamacare is no longer obamacare as we
worked on it and managed
it very well we stabilized it got
premiums down very substantially that
was alex and that was sema you did a
fantastic job
but it's still unacceptable to me
because it's too expensive
and doesn't really do the job as well as
we could have
so what we have now is a much better
plan
it is no longer obamacare because we've
gotten rid of the worst part of it the
individual mandate
and made it much less expensive a lot of
that was through
good management we manage it properly
we have tremendous people working on it
simultaneously with all of this
we are burning in a lawsuit to end this
ill-conceived plan
i'm in court to terminate this uh really
really
terrible situation if we win we will
have a better and less expensive plan
that will always protect individuals
with pre-existing conditions
if we lose what we have now is better
than the original
the original version of obamacare by far
much better much better again we will
always
protect patients with pre-existing
conditions so today i'm
laying out my vision for the future of
american health care
with the america first healthcare plan
as we restore america to full strength
the first
healthcare plan will be a core part
of our national renewal in a few moments
i'll sign an executive order outlining
the three pillars of my plan
and directing my administration to
implement these
critical reforms the first pillar
of my plan is more choice more
choice for the american patients
the last administration severely
restricted consumer choice through the
greatest health care lie ever told
if you like your plan you can keep your
plan
if you like your doctor you can keep
your doctor
you remember that 28 times that was
stated by our president but it turned
out not to be true
when i took office more than 50 percent
of
counties nationwide orphan plans from
only a single insurance company
on the individual market starting next
month more than 90 percent of the
counties will have multiple options to
choose from which is really some
difference
under our plan you'll have the freedom
to shop for the option that is right for
you and your family
these options include new affordable
choices that cost up to 60 percent less
than obamacare think of that 60 percent
less
for example we're opening up short-term
plans that are much cheaper than
obamacare
and that can be customized to your
individual needs
we're also offering association health
plans that allow small businesses to
pull together and offer more affordable
policies to their employees
these are tremendous options that didn't
exist before we came into
office and through a massive expansion
of health
reimbursement arrangements millions of
americans will be able to shop for a
plan of their choice on the individual
market
and then have their employer cover the
full cost
furthermore i'll work to make individual
health care premiums
fully tax deductible that will be a big
difference
[Applause]
through these and other reforms we're
putting american patients back in charge
and we're putting them first
my plan will also revolutionize access
to
telehealth that's something that really
has taken off uh
during the pandemic it's taken off like
a rocket ship
it's increased close to 9 000
nobody was using it and when we had the
pandemic
they started using it then they started
really liking it then it started getting
better and better
bill now it's up to nine thousand
percent who would think that right
one of the few things that we got from
this
disaster that came from china
when we rapidly expanded its
availability for medicare
beneficiaries during the pandemic the
number of
telehealth users increased so
incredibly to 14 000 a week it was
1.7 million it was increasing at levels
that
nobody's ever seen before just about any
kind of a program this is
the future of health care we will ensure
all americans have the freedom to
consult with doctors from the safety and
convenience of their homes
the second pillar of my plan is lower
costs for
families and seniors lower costs
for years patients have been shocked to
receive
unexpected bills for thousands of
dollars in medical services
they never agreed to the first america
first healthcare plan bans this
deeply unfair practice we will end
surprise medical billing
the days of ripping off american
patients are over
my plan also includes the vital reform
of price
transparency
and trace transparency is great for the
great doctors the good doctors and it's
also great for the
great and good hospitals that's where
it's really fantastic for them too in
addition obviously to the patients
for the first time ever we will create
true competition in healthcare
both hospitals and insurance companies
will be required to post
all of their prices online this
transformative policy will allow you to
see your exact
out-of-pocket cost before you go for
treatment
making it easy to shop for the best
price
costs will come way down some people
think this will have a
bigger impact than health care itself
it's a tremendous thing
no matter where it's been put it's been
an incredible
service and it's it's worked miracles
it's been
brilliant for patients next time taking
on the lobbyists and the special
interests to lower
the price of prescription drugs for
years american patients have subsidized
socialist nations
and you know that uh we talk about it
all the time
congress they come over we've been
talking about it for a long time they've
been talking about it for years they
know the problem but we've been
subsidizing socialist nations and others
by paying the highest drug prices in the
world by far
and yet with the largest purchaser of
prescription drugs by
far and this is all while countries got
away with paying
so much less so much less incredibly
less
under my plan we will pay the exact same
price as other countries that's at the
lowest level
so we will be matching the lowest price
with what's now many times the highest
price
and we won't pay a penny more what will
happen is the lower prices will come up
a little bit
but you'll get discounts of 40 50 60 80
90 who knows percent numbers that you
wouldn't even believe
and we were the only ones in 52 years to
bring drug prices down
last year they went down as you know
[Applause]
but that was before this they went down
just a little bit but just a little bit
was the only time
in 52 years now they're going to go down
massively favored nations this will lead
to
a very large savings for american
families and plummeting drug prices they
will plummet
the obama biden administration caved to
big pharma and allowed drug prices to
explode
the only bad part about this transaction
is that they are advertising like crazy
make sure you don't elect trump and all
it means is that your drug prices are
coming down so it's
it's incredible they have unlimited
money for ads but they're taking ads and
every time you see an ad
just think that your drug prices are
coming down i now understand why other
politicians wouldn't do it
because it was a very easy thing to do
but it took a certain amount of courage
i will say that
[Applause]
so it means that i'm taking on big
pharma like never before nobody's done
this before they understood favorite
nation's favorite nations is you get the
best price as the lowest no matter where
it is anywhere in the world
so if germany's paying 10 cents for a
bill and we're paying two and a half
dollars for the same exact bill from the
same place
same plant same genius scientists same
everything
same laboratory we get the same price as
they do
you're talking about numbers that are
unthinkable
favorite nations clones so it's really
something and they're
attacking me viciously we know that and
uh
they're attacking me really because i'm
fighting for you but it's worth the
fight
it's worth the fight i think
and i i can say this i think i don't
think it's confidential
our chief of staff is here mark meadows
from a very
great state known as north carolina
that happens to come from north carolina
that's good stuff he wanted to be here
for that reason probably more than
even listening to this because you've
heard it but mark will tell you that big
pharma
is calling and negotiating and
negotiating and they want to make a deal
and there's a deal somewhere but it's uh
it's something that's taking place right
now so they're negotiating but
this is where we are and they're
negotiating for one reason before that
they wouldn't even think about
negotiating with any
other administration they would uh they
cannot believe this is actually
happening
and if we can make a deal we will but
mark you're negotiating
literally as we speak right so if he
doesn't make a great deal we'll blame
north carolina okay so that's great now
mark is a
real pro at this understands it
complicated business
but he understands it very well today my
administration's taking action
on every piece of the executive order i
signed on
prescription drug importation in july
the american people pay an average of
over listen to this
three times more for medicine than
canadians
so you could be two feet away on each
side of the border
three times more and that's the way it
is
canada is far more than many other
countries
my plan will allow states wholesalers
and pharmacies to do something
career politicians have promised for
decades because it was very simple as an
idea
but never delivered we will finally
allow the safe and legal
importation of prescription drugs from
canada
so this means
so this means a state or whatever can go
to canada and buy your drugs
for a fraction of the price that they're
charging right now
massive numbers of tremendous numbers
florida wants to do it colorado wants to
do it many states want to do it
and they will be doing it but that's
still higher than the favorite nations
so his favorite nations kicks in i think
that probably beats everybody no matter
where you are no matter where you're
trying to buy this will be
a game changer for american seniors and
by allowing you to do this through
canada
we're doing it very very quickly so it
goes very fast
and the new rule goes into effect as of
today is that fast enough i think so
what do you think
my congressman
the america first healthcare plan
includes another historic provision to
benefit our great seniors
under my plan 33 million medicare
beneficiaries will soon receive
a card in the mail containing two
hundred dollars
that they can use to help pay for
prescription drugs nobody's seen this
before these cards are incredible the
cards will be mailed out
in coming weeks i will always take care
of our wonderful senior citizens
joe biden will be doing this
and this is also partially because of
the tremendous money that we're going to
be saving with
the favored nations and various other
things that we've done
we've approved more affordable generic
drugs than any administration
in history i had no idea but i had had
many doctors who have great respect for
by the way come to me and
i said well what's the difference
between this and this one is a very well
known name
one is just a pill and a bottle with
no tag on it and they said zero i said
a little bit better write the name zero
and yet the name brand will cost
five and even ten times more money than
the generic so we've approved
more generic drugs than anybody at a
rapid pace too
we're also requiring that low-income
patients receive the benefits of
government discounts on insulin
and the epipen and that you know that is
a big
uh that is a big deal that is a big deal
insulin is one of the most common
medicines for seniors
and this is something that uh sema
worked on so hard
insulin prices soared under the last
administration
like you wouldn't believe right seymour
under my plan hundreds of thousands of
medicare patients will see their insulin
costs capped
at just 35 a month that's a 66
cost reduction
and this feature will be available
available on over
1 600 medicare plans that seniors can
begin signing up for
starting october 1st and under certain
circumstances seymour
it's literally almost free this
insulin which they were just
is close to being free even lower than
the 35
a month so you did a fantastic job in
that thank you very much
and sema would come to my office sir i
have something so exciting she worked on
that for a long time and getting that
done but it was it is exciting
if you need insulin a lot of people were
going without it they just couldn't
afford it now they can definitely afford
it
we'll accelerate our relentless effort
to save seniors money on their premiums
since i took office we reduced medicare
part d premiums by 12
medicare advantage premiums are also
down dramatically a 44
reduction in north carolina
43 lower in pennsylvania
and a 54 lower price in michigan
so that's something and we have them all
over the country
all over the country there are numbers
just like that will ensure that all
seniors pay the same price for the same
service whether at a hospital a surgery
center or a doctor's office
this will save seniors billions and
billions of dollars a year we're talking
about the billions
and it also saves our government a lot
of money but will save our senior
citizens billions of dollars
a year fantastic job we're putting into
place the largest package of saving for
seniors of any administration in history
no administration is even close to what
we've done and i've said it
having to do much more than even health
care there's no administration in its
first three and a half years that's done
anywhere close to the things we've done
and i never even get criticized for
saying it that must mean it's true right
my congressman or my great senator
under the democrat plan costs will
skyrocket our seniors will lose the
benefits they paid into their entire
i mean their entire lives tremendous
amounts of money all to finance
socialism and open borders we're just
helping other countries countries that
aren't even friends of ours but we help
our friends and we help
socialism all over the world and we hurt
our people and we're not doing that any
longer
as long as i'm president
no one will lay a hand on your medicare
your medicare is going to be safe
and it's going to be solid
the final pillar of america first
healthcare plan is
better care that's better care for
american patients
the historic action i'm taking today
includes the first ever executive order
to affirm it is the official policy of
the united states government to protect
patients with pre-existing conditions so
we're making that official
we're putting it down in the stand
because our opponents the democrats like
to constantly talk about it and yet
pre-existing conditions are much safer
with us than they are with
them and now we have it affirmed this is
a firm
signed and done so we can put that to
rest they'll say it anyway
because it's disinformation
disinformation
same thing goes for social security you
remember during the last
campaign four years ago they kept saying
i was going to
destroy social security i made social
security stronger better
they will be the ones that destroy
social security because they're going to
destroy our country
they will destroy our economy so social
security nothing happened i keep saying
whatever happened to social security
remember he's going to immediately
attack now just the opposite
his social security is 100 with me but
it's
not a hundred percent with them any
health care reform legislation that
comes to my desk from congress must
protect the pre-existing conditions or i
won't sign it and i made that pledge and
i made that pledge
last week but now i'm making it in
writing we're putting it down and we
have it signed and we have us here
the new democrat lie is that they will
cover pre-existing conditions but in
truth the socialists take over
economic shutdowns that they talk about
if you look at
this state frankly where you have
democrat governors democrat leaders
those those states are in very very
bad shape with all of their shutdowns
pennsylvania you take a look at what's
going on in pennsylvania with a shutdown
we just won a big
court case where a judge a great federal
judge ruled it unconstitutional what
they were doing they're hurting people
there's damage on the other side of a
shutdown people don't realize with
suicides and
drug use and all of the alcohol
it's a terrible thing that happens and
michigan's another state the shutdown is
very
severe by the way on november 4th
i'm sure everything will be up and
they'll announce on the evening
of november 3rd that we're opening up
unless these unsolicited ballots don't
come in for weeks and weeks and weeks
you know they want them to
uh come in over a long period of time
it's going to be a very interesting day
november 3rd it's going to be a very
interesting day and coverage for
illegal immigrants will collapse our
economy
will collapse under their system and
make your health care system
totally insolvent you know that as great
doctors and people who do this you know
that what they're doing is
socialized medicine and it's not
acceptable it's going to be a disaster
in terms of quality and cost
it'll ruin our country under their plan
you'll
lose your doctor again and you will lose
your coverage you will lose everything
to do with what we're talking about on
my walk
i will never let the radical left
take away your health care you'll always
have health care
[Applause]
the america first health care plan will
deliver another long-awaited reform we
will put
you in control of your own medical
records
we'll require doctors to make your
records available electronically
and you alone them and you'll control
them and they will be portable
you'll be able to work seamlessly with
all of your medical providers it'll make
your life a lot easier
much much easier the previous
administration
led by sleepy joe biden spent 35 billion
dollars and failed to get it done
you know that 35 billion dollars
where they failed we are delivering to
give
critically ill patients access to
life-saving treatment
i also signed right to try you know what
right to try is i'm very
to me right to try is
is so great it's so great and what i
think i'd like to do i'll do it really
quickly
i'm going to run through just a quick
list of
accomplishments that we've done and you
know we've really become
the healthcare party the republican
party and nobody knows that
the news doesn't talk about it
but i'm going to just say i mean it's a
list of things that we've done
and it'll go quickly but i just thought
i'd take it out i said you know i'd like
to read that to the audience of
professionals today and this is just a
partial list
we repealed the individual mandate
eliminated obamacare's health insurance
medical device and the cadillac taxes
that's a big deal
people forget all of this they say i
wonder who did that
could it have been joe biden he doesn't
know what it is
expanded association health plans
increased availability of short-term
limited duration plans
expanded health reimbursement
arrangements big deal
lowered prescription drug prices and you
will see them at a level that you will
never have
you'll never see this again they will go
down so low
and as i said we had the largest annual
decrease we had the only decrease over a
52-year period
more generic prescriptions approved
savings america saving america an
estimated
2.6 billion dollars in the first 18
months of
the administration alone so in 18 months
we saved 2.6 billion with
generic drugs signed four executive
orders to lower prescription drug prices
signed legislation banning pharmacy gag
clauses
does that make sense to you
i mean what what people were under what
even the pharmacists
had to do was it made them it was
embarrassing to them
took executive action to ensure price
transparency in healthcare that'll be
one of the biggest things and most
people have no idea what it means
i said some people said that's bigger
than healthcare required hospitals to
post standard prices on the internet
modernize and strengthen medicare with
more options more benefits and lower
premiums substantially
improve kidney care such a big deal with
more transplants and better treatment
kidney care is so tough for people with
a problem
very substantially lowered the price of
insulin as we said for our seniors
invested in advances in generic therapy
for
sickle cell disease big
launched a 500 million dollar initiative
to find cures for childhood cancers 500
million
combative drug demand we
really went very very strong on drug
demand and the opioid crisis
with expanded access to medication
assisted treatment and life-saving
nalaxone nalaxone
opioid prescribed decreased by over
35 so if you look at
the opioid obviously horror show
it decreased by over 35 percent since
january
2017. we've worked very very hard on
that
launched findtreatment.gov to connect
those with
substance abuse disorder to treatment we
have an incredible situation
spinetreatment.gov
past right to try to give critically ill
patients access to
life-saving cures where it hasn't been
approved yet by the fda
incredible and and by the way
many of you know what that has meant we
have had some
examples of success that on right to try
that have been amazing
launched an initiative to end aids hiv
aids
in america we think in six years it will
be
largely eradicated who would have ever
thought and this could have started two
years before i got there but they chose
not to do it but we have and we've
launched the initiative
it's into its almost fourth year and
at the time we did it was going to be 10
years at the end of 10 years now six
years we're already down to six
it will largely eradicate
aids hiv aids in america who would have
thought that it's incredible when i
first heard about it
when i first heard about it i said why
wouldn't they have started it early but
they didn't
expanded access to telehealth especially
in rural
and underserved areas telehealth signed
historic
va choice legislation that's a big deal
that's a big deal it's the real
it's the real choice not the weak choice
the very very weak the choice that
didn't mean anything
but it's been a tremendous success and
we just got a 91
approval rating from our vets the
highest we've ever had by
by a lot
and we also while we're at it we signed
accountability va accountability that's
where people don't love our vets if they
don't take care of our vets you couldn't
do anything about it
you have to they'd have to live in hell
with these vets
with uh with the people that we're
supposed to be taking care of
and uh we have a thing called va
accountability
they're accountable now if they don't
treat our vets
great if they don't take care of our
vets if they don't love our vets our
country
we can fire that we can say you're fired
we can fire again pa accountability
that's a big thing so va choice va
accountability took
executive action to prevent veteran
suicide and launch the 24-hour veteran
hotline for suicide
and it's really working
and signed the largest ever increase in
child care development block grants
those are just those are just some of
the
uh those are some of the things that
we've done
we've done actually a lot more than that
but we have to get back to business here
right those are things that we've done
and nobody has any idea when you look at
a list like that
democrats have never done anything like
that under the democrat socialist agenda
an avalanche of regulation would
extinguish the flame of excellence that
makes america the center
of scientific discovery groundbreaking
treatment
and life-saving cures our all-out war
against the virus we've lifted
bureaucratic barriers and marshalled
america's scientific industrial and
technical brilliance and we do have
total brilliance some of it's in this
room by the way in case you don't know
i will apply as really as some of the
people right great bill
some incredible people in this room i'll
apply the same
determination to accelerate medical
breakthroughs
in all areas including for alzheimer's
diabetes
generic treatments for sickle cell
disease early detection of cancer and
much much more
all ready to improve care for americans
with kidney disease we enable patients
to receive at home dialysis
and we're investing in the creation of
an artificial kidney we're getting very
close
and we introduce critical incentives to
make more cases available for
transplant a change that will save tens
of thousands of lives where people have
to go through with
kidney disease is incredible it's
incredible
they work so hard i said how do they do
they can live
a long life but it's so much work to do
it that they literally one doctor told
me that
they die of hard work it's such a job
to go and i guess dialysis etc it's such
a hard job
that they die of of literally they die
of
just hard work it's it's incredible what
we've done
there and what we're doing and
especially with some of the research
that's been done what we're coming up
with you'll be seeing it very soon i
believe
as we invest in the future we will
permanently bring our medical supply
chains back home
we will produce our medical supplies
pharmaceuticals and treatments right
here in the united states right here in
north carolina
we're going to bring a lot of business
to if you remember puerto rico used to
do it and then they
brought tax legislation that destroyed
that whole thing they all left but they
were very happy in puerto rico we're
going to bring it back to puerto rico
and
many of our states that uh that we'll be
doing it and north carolina i see is on
the list as being a very top one so
we're going to bring it back to north
carolina the country
and we'll reverse the disastrous and
heartless decision
joe biden made in 1996 to shut down the
pharmaceutical industry in
puerto rico it took place in 1996 biden
shut down the whole
puerto rico uh industry this was a very
good industry they were doing a
fantastic job and one day it was just
literally god biden shut it down with
what he did with taxes and
it was it was a disgrace but we will
bring it back
under our leadership american medicine
will make the biggest breakthroughs the
largest leaps the most exciting strides
and the most outstanding discoveries
before i sign a historic executive order
implementing this ambitious agenda let
me introduce two americans great
americans who will benefit from
our policies julia strathopolis
was born in freeman sheldon syndrome
with
with the freeman sheldon syndrome which
is tough
an extremely rare muscle and bone
disorder under the previous
administration julia's family saw their
premiums on
the individual market skyrocket to 3
000 a month and more her parents had to
go without a health insurance just to
afford coverage for their children
since i was elected their families
premiums have been slashed by
more than 40 percent and we're going
down further
and everyone is now covered and julia
always has access to the doctor she
needs
julia we are with you i don't know where
you are julia where is julia
wow thank you thank you
you look great julia thank you that's
great thank you julia
it's a great story but we're inspired by
your courage thank you very much
also with us is sharon leader a
financial planner from
nearby concord after spending less than
24 hours in the hospital and receiving a
few basic tests
she received surprise bills that added
up to four
thousand dollars that's a lot of money
despite having insurance sharon
those days will soon be over because
we'll end surprise medical building once
and for all
where is sharon hi sir
that's why they call it surprise billing
if you got home and you were surprised
they sent you the bill you opened it up
you thought it was going to be 25
and it was a little more than that right
that's great well we're taking care of
it thank you very much
we're standing up for our people
we're standing up to special interest
we're taking on the powerful lobbyists
we're stopping the radical socialists
and
communists to be honest with you i think
we've got us a little bit
above socialism or below it if you want
to call it that way
but we are standing up to both whichever
one you want to choose
and we are fighting for the incredible
people of north carolina
incredible people or people i love i
love the people
we named as you know my grandchild is
then carolina
[Applause]
beautiful carolina my most beautiful
child
we're providing better care and more
choice at a
lower cost substantially lower cost
we're delivering a healthier safer
brighter and more prosperous future for
every citizen
in our magnificent land because we are
proudly putting america first it hasn't
happened for a long time
on behalf of all americans i will now
sign
the executive order i want to thank you
all for being here god bless you
god bless north carolina and god bless
america thank you very much
[Music]
that's a lot of work
that's great
hi junior
this is a big one
oh
[Applause]
this is
thank you very much everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
my
[Music]
uh
[Music]